other decisions as well there but he  went for style points with that final  move  king is seven i mean eta xf7 is  completely winning but he went with  bishop of six check which i  i think is a nice touch  yeah it's too beautiful not to be played  right yeah if you if you see this move  you kind of want to make it yeah it's  it's a little bit too cute to to not  make yeah thing of six i guess queen e5  czech is the cleanest strike queen yeah  i mean that is a choice but yeah this is  yeah and then we should take c oh no no  no no bishop quintex it would be a  mistake because we give the  we give the  square  yeah this was basically the line that  immediately had in mind maybe maybe  queen h4 wins on the spot as well but  yeah just  to to illustrate that probably does yeah  but  and then gtx f6 runs into it xf7 check  just go here yeah yeah finish yeah you  get made it on the g8 square